COACH LAVIOLETTE.
>> Will: WE ARE UNDERWAY , HERE
FABBRO.
SHERRY BRINGS IT IN.
WE DID.WITH ASSISTANT.
THIRD MAN IS .
A PASS.
A
THIS IS A DANGEROUS SITUATION.
I DO NOT KNOW IF THAT IS. TIME.
ROMAN JOSI,
05 WILL DO TO THE NET.  --
FROM SCHOOL OF ROCK.
>> HE'E'ON-ONE.
OUT OF THE BOX.
McCARRON. FORSBERG KEPT THE CRO
WATCH THIS.
NT IN.
HIT THE BACK BAR.
I DO NOT KNOW IF
>> Referee: AFTER THE RELLY RE
TURNING INTO OFFENSIVE CHANCES.
>> Will: WE DIDN'T HAVE TIME TO
SHOW>> Will: FORSBERG, TRYING T
SHOOT IT THROUGH ELLER.
DUCHENE.
FABBRO, , THE
PREDATORS GET A BOUNCE.
AFTER SO MANY
TIPPED.
SCORE.ANCE FOR SAROS.
WHAT A
UNFORTUNATE TURN OF THEEN DOING
THE DAY HE GOT TO THE NHL.
HE IS GOING  IT UP THE ICE AND
OUTHE CLOCK.
TIME TICKING AWAY.
THE PREDATORS, THEY PLAYED A
GOOD HOCKEY GAME.
I DON'T KNOW HOW GOES.
>> Will: